I had an appointment with a
Portuguese investor in my calendar and I did
n't really
remember that it was about Cristiano.
To be honest, I wasn't
really prepared for the appointment. I
thought, what's
the point?  I made the appointment
and then shortly before the appointment
I took another quick look and
then it was CR7 Invest and that's when I
noticed it, but maybe that was
the reason why it
worked out quite well because it was a pretty
relaxed conversation  I was
n't prepared at all but then I did
n't hear anything more from him and
then I
wrote it down mentally and after three months
an email came. Yes, I'm sorry, it took a
while, but Christiano would
like to invest. Welcome
to  OMR Podcast big watch update with
the Mr uh at least in my
perception cycle or my
field of perception there is no one who
knows things better and, above all,
has built more exciting things than Tim
Stracke from Chrono 24 we
last spoke 3 or 4 years ago and you are
building from Germany  out one of
the largest marketplaces in general, that's why
I thought I'd take a look,
maybe a bit of an indicator on
the economy, how's the
uranium world doing, welcome Tim,
thank you very much, hello Philip, first of all,
congratulations on all the developments,
we have to talk about it, you have
some exciting investors in there
won football star Ronaldo
and others possibly you also said
last time after we spoke I think
a larger round of financing
was done somehow 100 million
went into it again separately so it
all sounded great and it was also in the
last few years it was an
incredibly intense, exciting time  The
corona time after it was somehow
pure panic for 5 se weeks
obviously played into our hands, like many
other e-commerce companies,
um the wind that
pigs could fly or elephants
that have often fallen here is
the sentence and as  When Corona was over, there
was another crazy boom, especially in the Uren area,
the prices exploded and that
played into our hands again. Currently it's a bit more
challenging, I have to say the
prices have normalized a bit again
and
I would say I have to intervene a little more in the steering wheel,
but it has been an incredibly
intense and exciting and
eventful four years since we
last met here to
briefly mention a few numbers
to
make your business tangible what
percentage of the world's business  Luxury watches
are somehow
registered with you or run through
the various places on the
marketplace, so the trading volume via
Chrono 24 is around
2 billion euros per year, although
you have to say that we also count the
transactions with them  were initiated via the platform
but were processed outside of the
platform but also
the platform where the money actually
flows through our accounts is over a
billion euros per year and
in the long term we would like to
know every watch lover in the world. We also believe
that every second luxury watch lover in the world
Watch lovers worldwide use Chrono 24
and we are also there and
try to know all the watches that
exist worldwide and it is estimated
that there are watches worldwide worth around
7,700 billion euros, so in the
drawers there is also your
beautiful IWC
NAT and  We have a very
interesting feature where you
can take a photo of the watch or
enter the reference on the website and
then track the value of
your watch collection over time
and 7 to
8% of all watches in existence worldwide have now been
uploaded there  and are sometimes
tracked daily, i.e. the total value of the
watches in our watch collection. These are
not watches that we offer for sale,
unfortunately, but
people keep such securities in your
depot, so their B is essentially a
depository performance for watch collectors, well the
watch is still in the  Drawers at
home but it's registered with us,
so it's basically
the watchlist or your online
portfolio and the total value
of these watches is around 50 billion euros
and that's a number that
makes us very proud  then another 50
billion, the reference number, the
total value of
what is estimated at 700 billion euros,
so almost 10% of the
urenmarkt luxury market can be
7%, so to speak, exactly okay, okay and Lu
but they are not necessarily
all offered for sale, so they  The
majority of it doesn't, so you also
have your IWC, which I hope
is also in our store but isn't
offered for sale, of course,
and tell me where does a luxury watch start,
so now IWC is a luxury watch, I
understand and Rolex probably too
and what so where  Apple watch doesn't,
so Rolex is almost at the top
end, of course there's
no limit at first, but that's it,
the watches have become
very, very expensive in the last few years,
so we always say that
to a large extent it's also on  The brand depends on the brand, so
if it is a luxury brand one of
the top 40 50 Swiss watch brands and
even if a watch
is perhaps 20 or 30 years old and perhaps
only costs 5 6 700 €, from our
point of view it is definitely a luxury watch  There
isn't a very precise definition,
but in the end, luxury is always what
you don't really
need, but where you
want to treat yourself to something nice,
and we're all aware that
a watch for €5 also tells the time well
can and you don't have to spend 500 € on it
now let's say very briefly for everyone who
hasn't heard the first episode,
now you're wondering, okay, is a guy who
can immediately grab numbers from the market, who creates such a worldwide platform,
who speaks German  I'm
from Karlsruhe, but let's take a
quick look at how
did you come to set up such a thing
back then? In principle, there are
three passions that I
was able to bring together. I've always had
a fascination for
entrepreneurship, I come from one
Entrepreneurial family and both of my
parents come from entrepreneurial families,
so I think that was
something I was born with and
I always had a fascination
for mechanics and very early on,
mechanics on my wrist, which is why
I always had an enthusiasm
for them  Watches
m and at some point there was also an
enthusiasm for marketplaces. I
found this model of
marketplaces where you basically give people who
maybe don't know a category that
well or don't even
have an overview of the market
the chance to buy something in a very short time
Selling or getting information like
only professionals can, I've
always found that fascinating in all
sorts of segments, I'm an incredible
fan of marketplaces and after I
more or less failed with my first company
and the second one
wasn't as successful either
I originally thought that he hoped I said
on the third occasion, so
now I'm doing something that I
primarily enjoy and that was
a marketplace for luxury,
that was the idea that came about in 2008
and we designed it very specifically
then in 2009 and we started in
March 2010 okay, so not that
long ago, well 13 years is
quite a journey and you
also have to say that we
originally planned
to found the company, but then we
decided  To buy the KRONO 24 brand or the
existing platform as part of an
asset deal, so we did
n't hire any employees, but the
chrone 24 brand was already a few years
older and therefore had
a bit of traction so that
today, if you look at the brand, we are
20  -th anniversary
this year the company is
only 13 years old okay and that means you
bought the platform for Apple and ID back then when we
saw the platform that it
might be two Apples and two eggs
but it was  Then it was significantly more expensive,
so the problem was that one of the
two sellers was an M&A consultant in his main job
and that's something I
don't recommend to anyone buying companies from M&A
consultants, which means we
somehow negotiated the price for 8 months
and it didn't
really change  moved and in the end we
just paid for it but we
never regretted it. I have to say we are
already talking about the million sum, yes okay and
that was what we had to
get together first, which was
n't that easy in 2009
was a phase where
nobody actually wanted to invest and the VCS we
spoke to at the time
said, well, you want to
buy something, that's not a VC business,
that's yes, that's a bout yes D I have to
talk to buout consultants B  byout
funds then approached a few buout funds
who
looked at it, it was a flawless VC
deal and that's why it was
n't that easy for us to
finance it at the time, also because the financial crisis
was almost at its peak or or shortly
afterwards and then  The Sparkasse
forzheim, which has a small private
equity subsidiary,
gave us the first start-up capital and
helped us manage this purchase,
okay, and how did you get it so big
in the last 13 years? We did
n't want it to be that big
So at the beginning we wanted to keep it really
small, I still know that there
are still a lot of employees or some employees with us today that we
promised that we didn't
want to have more than 15 employees and with
us there are around 500 so that's a long way off
But we
really wanted to keep it small for the first six years
because we weren't really sure
whether the market would really support it and we
invested very heavily in a very, very strong technical infrastructure at the beginning and always had that at the
beginning  The focus was on supply,
we always wanted to get as much supply as possible
onto the platform, so the offer
was always as many good,
interesting offers as possible from all over the
world and we put our money and
energy into
technical information structure and a good
offer and not into marketing and so on  I
think, looking back, that was a very
good decision because once you
have a strong technical basis,
the company can be scaled very well
and a good offer is
ultimately the best marketing you
can do and, looking back, that
worked extremely well  In the meantime,
you've just
said the number of employees and now
we're talking about 100 million in sales
that you'll be able to achieve this year. That
's the biggest order in which we're
currently moving, although sales for us
are just the fees that we
collect  but but they are on such
a scale and because we
are a company which I know the
question will now probably
come next which does not have such a
huge marketing expenditure and and has
always been run very lean and efficiently,
the company is also in the
vast majority of cases  In the last 13 years, it has
been very profitable in the last few years because
you actually have to create a 30% 40% margin on marketplaces. You
can definitely do that, and
we would
certainly be able to do that if we
wanted to do it today  But we are
clearly in the
mode at the moment where we still have a lot to do,
so I think the journey is
probably not in
the middle anymore, but we are
still at the beginning of what can still be done
We are still a relatively
lean product and believe that we
still have a lot to do,
but the company has already
become worth a lot, as we saw a
while ago when the last
round of financing that we could see
was 100 million
If someone invests 100 million with you,
then you can
assume that the overall valuation
would have been in the billions range  In
2021 it was
like that since then, fortunately, we didn't have to
do any more financing rounds and
I think that's a long way from now, you can
look at peer group multiples there.
Marketplace sales are no
longer worth as much as they were back then
because the market is currently
different  See, that's exactly what I mean, I mean
the sales have increased since we
did this financing round, so
our internal sales have probably
increased by %, so the business
developed very, very well after that, but the valuation is
of course at the other end
of the situation anyway  where they were two years ago,
I'm quite happy that we
're not on the stock market now and I
have to think about
how much the company is worth today,
so
I don't have to look at the share price, but we
always do  There
will certainly be half a billion or more, I do
n't think you have to worry about it,
um I'll explain again very briefly
that for everyone who missed the first episode
before then,
you'll take the fees I just said
For each transaction, how high
are they? They vary, so from
private individuals we take 6inh%.  So
like the real estate market in Hamburg
almost yes, we don't want to compare ourselves with them
um and
with commercial dealers it varies
a lot because we take different commissions for each brand
for different models,
which
range from 203% to
8 9% and how much  You currently have clocks
so live, so if you don't watch them, would you
even know? Yes, there are around 530,000 540,000
that we have right now from
120 different countries, a
large part comes from commercial
providers, we have around 3,000
commercial providers on the platform
and at any given time  There are around 30 to 40,000
private individuals who offer watches on
the platform, okay, and quite a few
who watch and that's probably the case in
some way. There are
often almost a million
people on the platform every day who are
looking for ears, not everyone buys it, but
the famous watch porn  yes watch
por would you say that, so to speak, now
your somewhat declining
trading volume you just said
or then accordingly then then
fee volume is also an indicator of
the global economy I mean in
Germany people think yes but many
others l is booming
that was just that  so that people now somehow
say okay, then I'd rather invest my money
again in some kind of interest-bearing
bonds or something like that or or how do
you explain that because you're global, so I
mean and the global economy is
actually growing or or was the chona
Hal particularly strong  Germany is
n't that big of a market for you or
Germany is for
us. Looking at it from the buying side,
Germany accounts for maybe 12 to 13%,
but of course we see that
growth in Germany
is weaker than in other markets
after this  coronabom there was
another crazy watch boom that catapulted the
prices, especially from the
family-run markets and brands, so
high that
Rolex AP Patek Philip the
prices have exploded, they have
risen by 6070% within a year and despite this  Extreme
price increase or because of this extreme
price increase, the demand was
increased again incredibly s that we
had an incredible amount of trading volume in the
first half of
2022 and after that the prices
normalized and have fallen significantly since April May,
especially for
these three brands and that's just what happened
20 30% yes or even more so we can
see that since January
the prices have been relatively
stable and that has also
led to
many buyers now waiting and waiting before they
want to buy again, which is
what I always do  say, if you had
bought an IWC instead of a Rolex two years ago,
you wouldn't have lost 50% now. Yes,
on the other hand, that's absolutely
true, so if you look at the performance of
the last 18 months or 15
months, then IWC has certainly
performed very, very well  On the
other hand, you also have to say that
IWC didn't really
take advantage of this hype in the previous 12 months,
so if you look at it from a two-
year perspective, you're
still doing very, very well with a Rolex AP and the Patk Philip
But because the
trading volume
was so extremely high in the first half of 2022, we also had
a
very, very strong comparative figure in the first half of the year when you compare it to the previous year and
for the first time in our
company's history we had no year-on-
year growth  Q3 we are again in a
situation where we
have positive growth figures if you look at sales
and the trading volume on the platform,
Q3 is again ahead of the previous year
q322 what percentage of the people are there
with you now, so to say,
are simply watch lovers and
how many are  In order to really make money with watches,
I think that makes it
quite difficult for you to separate them because
most of them, there are very very
few who are pure investors who
buy a watch without any emotions,
put the watch in a safe and
want to sell it to someone  very very
very rare and I would also say there
are very few people who buy such an
expensive watch who
don't care at all about the performance,
but in most cases it is
both. So you are already
interested in the brands in the
fascination of this precision mechanics
Design but of course the
value retention you get with such products
always plays a role in a purchase decision
otherwise people wouldn't
spend €50,60,70,000 on a mechanical watch. What
is the most expensive watch that
was traded here? The most expensive watch was
just the last one  Traded with us last week,
that was quite exciting, the bit
anti-cyclical F yes, I mean, I
said the prices have been
stable for the last six months and so on
and we're already noticing that
the first ones are
coming out of their waiting position and buying and  and
this watch in particular is probably a
signal that was a P Philip Nautilus,
one of the most iconic models from
the Patek philiip brand and then from the
Tiffany series, which was one of the
last Patek Philip Nautilus watches in
steel with a dial
in  the Tiffany color and it was just a
very luxury brand of its own or as a
jewelry one of the most popular
jewelry brands women have just been
bought by LVMH a few years ago
this French super entrepreneur
Ben on the exact same one is also there
but it was American  I also
bought it once, so I
bought the exact one that was the tiffany, that was shortly
after the watch came out. As far as
I know, I'm not
entirely sure and
I think it was sold to selected collectors for around €65,000
years 3 years and
this watch that was now
bought from us via the platform was
sold for 1.8 million dollars, um, are
you buying one? Yes, we have the
issue of data protection, so it was
bought by an Asian buyer,
but there  It must also be said that such a
transaction is not a
click and bye transaction via Chrono 24,
but we have a team of
private client advisors who advise our
customers who buy such expensive watches
very closely and also take
part in such a process  We then
went through them together and
the price was negotiated, we
mediated there and also had a
clearly intensive role in such a
transaction as
if you or I were to buy a Rolex there,
okay but of course we were really
happy about that  I was also really happy for the
team who managed this transaction
and that shows that
such watches can now be
sold and bought internationally over the Internet.
Money is somehow also relevant if you
think about it. Now 6% on 1.2 million,
you said no  It's
okay then, although something like this is
negotiated very individually here, okay, where we're talking about
is Mr. in Languages, so the lwm
as boss, he's also invested with you.
We were very pleased to have the
biggest name in the global
luxury industry
I was really happy to have that as a companion, that
was two
years ago. Yes, that was through various
contacts. The contact with the family
came about.
I have known one of his sons for a very long time, Frederik, who
has also been deep in the primary industry for a long time
Genan is currently at
Louis Vuitton but is
also responsible for the shopping business there, so this line
extension from Louis Vuitton and,
um, through various sites,
the contacts have come about that we know about this
family that invests his money
for a long time and
now z a good opportunity to
invest than this round
two years ago STF tight the the children so
the sons from there I know some of them and
have been in contact with him for a long time
I haven't met him personally yet there
are others  Investors
who are even better known and who you
met in person. I saw that
we urgently need to talk about it. A
few months ago, I think a few weeks ago,
the news went out that
Cristiano Ronaldo, the great footballer, is now
investing with you. How do you get something
done? Yes, we do  We
thought about it a long time ago that we,
of course, or we always think about
who we would like to have as a company.
In the beginning there were a lot of
venture capital investors and
we were particularly looking for investors who were
very familiar with marketplaces.
Then we were fine  The topic of luxury is also
important, so for connoisseurs, I
of course prepared it while my colleagues
here looked at the commercial register
and there is Fabrriis Grinder in
there, so the global
business angel marketplace, so I think you can
say Sprints Capital is also a
company that is known worldwide for it  is
to invest in places, so this
marketplace expertise, you can already tell that with
you, so we won't
say anything, but if you're
interested in it then you'll see that in your
case, you're not always
striving to get the best and  I
think we managed to do that too, including
inside partners who are
very familiar with marketplaces and also
know the American market very well and Devin, who
was originally in the board, is also a
watch lover, so we
decided that very consciously when we
wanted to have it and then at some point
the idea came to say, well, from the
luxury sector, we also
addressed various families and
of course the Bernard
an family was our greatest wish here, but
also one of the founders of yuker porte, for
example, and some of them  We have
been very successful in the rement group
and then
we thought about it some time ago
that we would also like to have famous
watch collectors in our circle of shareholders
because they
are of course better known to the public and
can radiate even more trust, I have to say
You don't do that with those with money because they
all work so hard now
and give you some kind of input. You
do it more or less
because of the signal effect that
later investors will see, okay,
people have already
invested money in them  really have an idea
W because the S operationally because really
give daily tips that's not like that I assume
that's not the case but we've
always noticed that when we
bring in investors who have a strong
signaling effect that it has an incredibly
positive effect on the company  Business
also has to do with potential partnerships but
also with the search for additional
investors. I really
noticed what a charisma inside
Partners had when they invested with us.
We were still a
super small company but suddenly
other investors were
interested in us  who had so much trust in
Insight that they
transferred their trust to us and
we then thought about this step
that we would also like to
take in private and
thought about who are the
most renowned watch collectors who are also
a big one  Notoriety and
the first name that
came to mind was Cristiano
Ronaldo, who wasn't on the list. Well, there
were a few other athletes on
the list. We also had conversations with some in the rap scene
and had
some very interesting promises
But we weren't so sure whether
the values ​​fit together so well, so
we turned down some of them,
including some big, well-known
names who would have liked to invest with us,
who are also known for their
passion for watches, and
then we were the first to come
decided in favor of Cristiano Ronaldo and how
does something like that work then someone from
the investment circle speaks to him or you
yourself or you write so we
have, of course, we have a large
circle of shareholders and of course this circle
also has a large
network and then the contact is in
this  In the case of general Atlantic,
specifically, it was Achenenberg, who made
the intro to the
manager. Yes, that's exactly who made the
intro to Cristiano
Ronaldo's manager and I spoke to them
on the phone once and didn't hear anything else,
a Portuguese guy or
exactly me  I had an appointment with a
Portuguese investor in my calendar and I did
n't really
remember that it was about Cristiano.
To be honest, I wasn't
really prepared for the appointment and I didn't really
think about who
gave it to me  I made the appointment and then
shortly before the appointment I took another
quick look and then it was CR7
Invest and that's when I noticed it, but
maybe that was the reason why
it worked out quite well because
it was a pretty relaxed conversation
I wasn't prepared at all but
then I didn't hear anything more from him
and then I
wrote it down mentally and after three
months an email came. Yes, I'm sorry, it took
a while, but
Christiano would like to invest and
then we'll talk  We didn't disclose the sums of 10 to 20
million that
we didn't
disclose, it was like he would have liked to
invest more, but for us
of course the sum wasn't the
deciding factor, what was important to us was that
it was a significant sum, it should be
a significant sum  for us and for
se
um it was a
significant amount but now
no one that would have completely changed our circle of shareholders yes
you can also
see D now receives something 1% no exactly
it receives a
manageable amount um and
um well  The money was actually the
reason why we
wanted to win him over, but because we also
find it exciting for us to
have someone like that in our circle of shareholders. He's not a testimonial either,
so we booked him as a
testimonial, he was
invested and we were really happy
that we were able to meet him
and take a photo together
and that photo
went pretty viral and
of course we weren't happy about that but that
means in the end you're doing it because of that
photo  So you actually want to do that,
so you can reduce it to that, I
think you do it because you
can use it to express that a person
who a lot of people trust
also trusts Chrono 24 with money and
this trust
is now transferred via a photo  or via
an Instagram post
that he kindly made, but there
was no contractual
agreement at all, he did it because he
likes us, because he likes us and because he
probably also found the meeting
very nice,
especially Cristiano Ronaldo than me  I've
looked at it before and
seen it as an unreservedly positive thing because there
are also accusations that have been made against him
over the years on
all sorts of levels, that's the case with many
celebrities. I don't think anything
has been substantiated for a long time. I do
n't know exactly
You do something like that or you say okay, that's
too hot or does the test beforehand?
We checked that and that's
why we also interviewed some people
who had already agreed on their own initiative,
especially in the rap sector, where the
CVs are of course often a
bit more complex
To put it mildly, we've
had a look at it. It's
probably with such
global fame as
Cristiano is now that nobody has it anymore and even
if you look back 10 or 20 years,
there's always something that has
happened, but we already have him
as almost unrestricted
assessed it positively and didn't
notice anything to the contrary in all the conversations afterwards and what was your
personal impression of him? Yes, it
was a very impressive meeting,
so I took my son
with me who wants to become a professional footballer
and because I also thought
that might be the case
I didn't just
do it to please my son,
but also because I
thought it would create a
good atmosphere for the conversation and
it was also like that  We got there, we
first wanted to meet him privately
but then no in Lisbon, he's
currently building in Lisbon and his family is
in Madrid. The children are also at
school but he was near Lisbon and it
all happened at very short notice
and then  But he still has a
follow-up appointment then we moved it to the hotel
and we asked, do
n't we need meeting rooms? Nope,
we can do that here in a very relaxed manner
and he came without security, he had
n't even booked a meeting room and we did
n't have it either  There
was no security in the lobby.
Georgina was also there and then
we talked for half an hour in a totally
relaxed manner about watches, about family, about
all sorts of things and that was
really a very, very relaxed moment
and yes, for me he
really won  Man,
we also know something about watches, well I gave him
this watch that we were just talking about.
I thought it would actually be
the perfect watch if you really
want a special watch and it's
hardly available on the market and then
he looked and said
So I don't like classic watches more
into modern watches and if you
look at Cristiano's watch style, if you're
a little bit interested in us, you
might also
know him. Cristiano likes it when there are a lot of
diamonds on it and when it's
very very big  special and
of course this watch was
n't and he had Frank Müller
with him, completely set with diamonds, and I
also think that watches like this
just suit him as a person, yes,
but it was really awesome and then
we went after the appointment  I spent another
hour in Lisbon and then
walked through the city with my son.
I thought I could
take a look at Lisbon and then I told him that there
is a lot of discussion on the internet and
many people say that Cristiano
is probably the most famous person in the world  is definitely the person
who has the largest following with 600
million Instagram followers and other
opinions are still like Obama or Elon
Musk but if you also
include India China, especially the
younger ones, Cristiano Ronaldo is probably already
super famous and in
that  The moment I
say that, it lifts, I look to the left
and then I drove past us, even the car
waved again,
waved again and my son
also looked again, we
took another photo, yes and  That was somehow
so natural and so personal and that
was a very special moment, okay, what happened
so now you did
that and he also
made an Instagram post about it GL I was on
his organic post on his
account somehow  kindly and
afterwards it hit you hard,
well first of all my pulse really
kicked in when my
employee came in and said Tim, your
face is being seen by 600 million people right now
m well if you're honest when you look at
our traffic numbers  If you
look at the platform, we were already
ready to achieve three times the daily
load. Our
technology was more prepared and
we were very far away from that.
So if you
look at the access, not
much has been done. You could of course
see that, especially now  in Portugal
or if you looked at the German market,
but on a global
level it really wasn't
particularly strong, but that wasn't
the reason why we did it, it was
more about making sure that
people who know Chrono 24 anyway
or are on the platform with us
and
think about it: can I trust the platform
now, can I transfer 5 or 10
or even 20,000 €
and then get a watch, it
all works and we believe that a
brand like Christiano Ronaldo can
do the same  radiates and will help us a lot,
but where do people
perceive that? I mean, if somehow
I go to it today, you ca
n't see on the platform that he
's in your circle.
We've already communicated that to our users
We communicated this via our
newsletter,
we communicated this via push notifications
and we also had extremely strong
media coverage, even my
LinkedIn post went viral and
had over a million views, okay, so
that means in the end it's such an
investment  Trust signal or
a conversion lever at the end is exactly how
we see it and of course you ca
n't prove it within three weeks,
but we are firmly
convinced that something like this always
anchors itself extremely positively in the brand
and is very, very strong in the long term  Effect
has and are further partnerships
planned, so I think I watch a lot now,
not American basketball, there are
a few candidates. LeBron James
is a really big one and also AP
protagonist. If you
have contact, I would be very happy to
take him, but we have it
all the way now  We had a very positive experience
and are certainly
open to doing something like that again in the future
and believe that it
continues to have very, very positive
effects. If you do some careful research then
there are indications that you
have something in mind. So, we say
We've already had other conversations like this
and stay tuned, I'll say
okay, okay, what else is on your
roadmap, so it's kind
of the big
topic for you now, so if it's an ai fail, of
course we'll
think about it, but  We're
not the business model that ca
n't survive without e, we're also
realistic and we do
n't just attach an AI to every brand
in order to then position ourselves as an artificial
intelligence company,
but something like that was a five  When we
had the appointment in Lisbon, we
of course took a lot of photos and
Hauke, our
press employee, then
showed our marketing to the leerin and she said
Dannuke, how can this happen? Tim's shirt
isn't ironed, okay, oh and
you didn't mean anything bad, first of all I have
it  ironed but it's not my
core competency but then my guy said
no problem we can just get rid of it with
this new AI feature in Photoshop
and I promptly
entered an iron shirt after this
picture I had a shirt on yes and the
result was that I  I'm sitting next to
Cristiano Ronaldo and have a huge
iron in my hand and
well GT even has to use this picture in the
communication because it just
looks so bizarre. You're sitting next to
the most famous person in the world and you just have
a big iron so in
that respect we have to  With AI, maybe you
can learn a little bit about how to deal with it better, okay, but it's a different
topic that is
perhaps moving the market more now than it is now in AI.
I read a few weeks ago
that Rolex is also your biggest brand,
you told me, somehow almost
40% of your products are Rolex that are
traded, they have now
extended the chain of custody, so to speak, and have now
bought one of the largest jewelry chains
bucherer, so that was noticeable in the wider
economic world, I at
least read a lot about it,
how do you take it  So that was
definitely a step that, on the
one hand, if you
look at these two companies that have been
extremely closely linked for decades,
one of the
current RLE Buchere owners
started his career at Rolex with the internship  There are very close
relationships and he also
knew the Rolex founder personally,
so on the one
hand it was to be expected, but on the other hand
Rolex was a company that was always
extremely consistent in
not seeking direct contact with the end customer and
deliberately did so with its trading partners
and that was also part
of the legacy of Hans Wisdorf,
the Rolex founder, that these
trading partners will not be avoided
and it was even written down,
so far as we know,
it was a very, very
big step for Rolex  To
suddenly position yourself completely differently
and buy the world's largest watch dealer.
On the other hand, you have to say
that Jörg Bucherer, single, 87
years old, as far as I know, had no
relatives, no children, no wife,
and he didn't really have
any other option because
this company  no one else
could actually buy because this
company would be worthless without the Rolex contract,
so we estimate that
to 80% of Buchera's gross profits are probably generated by Rolex and
if Rolex had said what you can do at any time,
no, we'll name the
contract now then that's it  The company was worthless, so
no one
else could buy it, so it was
certainly a very exciting
negotiation between the two
parties. The industry was very
surprised. We do
n't expect any major changes for us in the short term. If I were an
authorized Rolex dealer,
I would  You're probably already
thinking about how stable this
partnership is in the long term. You could
also see it in the fact that the
watches of Switzerland shares fell by 20% that day
and Faith did
n't recover much after that,
but for you as a marketplace
you're keeping yourself slim  and uh there would now be
an expansion into retail or something like
that anyway, it doesn't make sense, we also did
our experiments during the corona phase
and also
invested in companies or
bought companies that trade in watches themselves
and also started building watches
ourselves  We have to take balanceheet
but also have to learn how difficult
this business is if you
want to do the AT scale, so my respect
for our
3,000 commercial customers has
increased incredibly after we
tried to do it ourselves.
This was also important to us
private sellers on the platform  to be able to offer the
opportunity
to sell watches directly to us, but here too
we have reduced this significantly
and are recognizing more and more
how important it is to focus on your own
strengths and we are
market place experts, we understand that bringing
buyers and sellers together
but the actual thing  Trading the buying
and selling of watches also
taking a big risk on us is
something we no
longer want to do in this area because there are always the old
stories about what kind of sales these
watch shops in Switzerland or something like that make if
you're in Zurich, I think  Since you
have a jeweler in a good location then
there's GLB I have stories about how they
somehow make 100 or something like that a year
with one branch, so the rumors
were that the largest Bucherer
branch in Lucerne
made almost half a billion in sales at its peak
hatale yes, that's what it was like in the
years 13, 14 and 15 when Chinese
consumers bought a lot of them in
Switzerland and they had
two three buses every day with
Chinese buyers who bought their watches there.
Is that true?
Now it's really that much, but it's
probably one of the
most successful retail spaces in the world,
probably even more successful
than the Apple Store in New York,
which is one of the most successful
To be house number I
think in in in in Japan Rakuten is
pretty strong in and in China
I think there's a luxury outlet from Alibaba
tetimall luxury what's the name of the Te luxury
the tetimor Luxury Pavilion there's in
China there's also some a big
game so China is  So the only
big market where we are not really
present yet, we have around 25
dealers from China who are also
doing their first business through us, but that is
still very manageable, so China is a
market that we are currently looking at very closely
and are currently doing our
first business there  We also have a small
team in China. What do you do? I mean,
how do you do generally
little marketing? You've already
told me that marketing is actually an EU thing.
How do you get an MA? That's not quite
right  We
already have a large marketing team and I
also believe that we are
now good at marketing
and have
improved very, very much in the last few years, but historically Chrono 24 is
a brand that is primarily about what it
offers and what it offers  supply and I have to
say frankly that it has also become very, very big through SEO
and there is no brand that has now
been built up with large amounts of marketing money, the same playbook in China,
so without marketing China, we are
now trying to get the Chinese supply onto
the platform and
just try it  The most interesting dealers
there are to list their watches
on the platform and we
also assume that
in the first step they will probably sell a lot to
Europe and perhaps also to America.
We will also
support that because the Chinese
buyers aren't there yet at the moment
We don't yet have the address that,
for example, has implemented the payment infrastructure so
that Chinese
buyers
can buy from us as smoothly
as we expect. We would
then do that in step Z. So that's
an issue and we're looking at it in Japan
We also have a very strong
supply now, so Japan is our third
strongest market from the
seller side and we are now
also seeing that we are
slowly ramping up the demand side and that
of course no on me and and
we are also getting bigger ones  Marketing
activities are certainly not around that,
so there is influencer marketing or what
exactly is there, we
really play the whole spectrum. We
also did experiments with TV advertising
in America for a while, and it
wasn't as successful as we had
originally hoped
We didn't set it up again,
okay, but in the USA, TV advertising says you
've tried influencer SEO
probably there too because
Google also plays a role, namely what
else can you do, so how do
you get such a marketplace up and running? That's
an exciting question  The most
important thing is supply and that's what gets
around among the watch lovers,
where of course we also play a lot
with our content Watches are becoming
increasingly we've
already addressed it a bit from
the passion category to a
bit too  an investment category,
so it's always both to a certain extent,
but there are increasingly users
who are more interested in maintaining the value of a
watch and
of course data plays an extremely important role, i.e.
how is which brand developing,
how are the prices of
which developing?  Models and
of course there is no one else
who has the same data quality as we
have and that is something that we are currently
making much more use of and
all this content we are getting
extremely positive feedback on, that is
a thing
and we are doing it now  Um,
collaborations
with various other
influencers, so basically we're playing the
keyboard as I said and we're
also noticing that it's
working increasingly better. You yourself are in the
USA and China and I'll be so much on the ground
in the USA next week
I've been in China again for a long time since last year, just before Corona,
but since Corona has
n't been so easy, it's been
too clear for a long time, now
it's just opening up again and now
I would use the chance again, but we
are now a company that
doesn't make much of a difference for ecological
reasons,
for reasons of cost, but also simply because
because it works really well today without
traveling and when will the
company go public? Well, you know
as much as I
probably
do  That somehow we are
very lucky that our investors
really have a lot of staying power
and those who were there very early on
just have such a good return that
they are also very relaxed about it and that they
can now take it a long way and
they will do so later  In any case, we do
n't really care that much about
going public at short notice, but if the
opportunity arises, i.e. if
both the stock markets and the
capital markets recover again, then
we would take the step,
um, you probably have to do that
a Birkenstock IPO which is as we
speak so the Birkenstock ipoase
look very closely at it because this is
also a German company in the luxury segment more
or less even an investment
from uh Mr. an so yes let's say
close to you a little bit yes there's
probably  IPOs that we are
looking at more closely right now in uh in America
instacard they are
already there we are looking more
at the marketplace IPOs so if we are
compared then it is
more technology and
marketplace companies and not so much
luxury companies Chrono 24  It's
not really a luxury brand either, we
're certainly a premium brand, but we do
n't see ourselves in the
peer group with other luxury brands. W would be a
peer group for you,
um yes, they're certainly companies
like ETI. It's a
bit difficult for me to say because of the
stock market price  Of course, things
have also developed very difficult at the moment, although there are
a few internal reasons for this, which
fortunately we don't have, but these
are probably more like the
companies that you
would look at global online marketplaces
and there are a lot of them
That's also quite good, but I also have to
say that those who are currently
going public are estimated to
be around 10 to 15% below the fair value, so
the IPO discount is extremely
high, you have to be aware of that
Think carefully if you sell your
shares at a 10 to 15 percent
discount, so to speak, that's what
we're hearing right now about what's being paid on the stock exchange,
so you're not getting the
fair value on the stock exchange, you're
no longer in the double digits
Percentage share is almost the same, so
you can roughly imagine it's
an important question for you now, so
W you look at what value
could come out of it and then you know, so
tim still has ST relevant
shares, I'm primarily just
interested  that the company
will be successful
and
right at the beginning we
sold a few of our founders in order to
take out the personal risk, so to speak, which
really led to a mind shift for us
and
was also really good for the company and that's
why we're here  We are now very
relaxed and can now
focus on the long-term development of the business
and our own participation doesn't play such a big role now, but rather
that we have the many millions of
euros that are at least somehow worth it on paper  It's
certainly worth a lot on paper, but you
also have to be honest.
Especially when you go public, it's
no longer easy to sell. That
goes on for many, many years.
As a founder, you can actually sell shares on the
stock exchange because  As soon as you
do that in something too strong,
if you sell too many shares,
then of course the
stock market price goes down quickly, so you have a
lockup and so you're not allowed to
sell at all, well you're not allowed to sell for up to a year and a half
and after that you're not supposed to  I think a
lot of people say that I think Bill Gates did
it that way: he
sold 8,000 Microsoft shares every week, completely
independent of the
stock market price development, so that he did
n't send any signals to the
capital market. I think Müller
also had a podcast like that, I mean the
podcast something like that  So I can
understand that in this respect it's no
secret that D also in public
but I think he also does it in the
about you case now not quite
Microsoft but probably
every day that he does that well and has
a few good times too  I do
n't know whether he was allowed to sell in the really good
time.
The BSE is there, I guess
not, but in the end if you
look at it in the long term it's probably
still correct, a bit
like this cost average in the end  You
always sell a little bit no matter exactly and at
some point you don't want to
think about
doing something good with the money or
doing other things
for consumption, you
probably don't need it and I do
n't brew it either and the fir in Kalsro is
already there  also a hen champion from kalsro
so yes so I don't have it that often either yes
we also thought about it at the time
where is the right location we
also flirted with Switzerland we
also flirted with Berlin but
because we are my co-greener and I
both  We have a close relationship with kazro
because our previous companies also
had them, we
chose kazro and have never
regretted it, so especially if you want to
set yourself up as a technology company,
this is a very very good
location
because of universities and so the proximity to
karlsro  I think it was the
first university in Europe to
offer computer science. As far as I know,
the first web server was installed in Kro in
Europe.
I wouldn't have thought that, but
on the other hand, we now notice
that in certain
segments we also have it in other cities  We need to
recruit more with
talent, but in other
areas, especially when it comes to marketing, it's
easier in cities like Munich and Berlin and with this in mind,
we now have another
location in Berlin where we also
recruit and are
now also in exceptional cases  open to fully remote
work, you also
had a phase where I think you
laid off around 100 people,
yes it was 13%, I think
it was
65 with other employees that
we had to part with, that was one of the
most difficult  Phases
but you also have to say we
grew so aggressively in the phase before that, we
recruited so much, I think we
hired a gross of 200 people in the two years before that, and
in many cases our company was
no longer properly balanced, we
had in some cases  There are far too many jobs and
still too few in some places
and then we consciously
made a very difficult decision that we said we have to
correct this now even though the
company was profitable at the time,
there was no
economic pressure to do so
but it was a strategic
decision
that we said we have to
reposition ourselves here again and we do
n't want to be so aggressive anymore
because we also noticed that we
were no longer as efficient as we would
like to be
and were of the opinion that  We
just
had to make up for what we may not have done perfectly in the last few years and
so in Germany we did it, we did
n't separate, we didn't give
notice, but we
offered severance packages
and then we had to take this step
But it really wasn't
easy for us and that was certainly
one of the hardest
business decisions for me, how close
you are with the CEOs of the big ones
or the owners of these
big families, the most important watch
brands apart from
IWC  I think Audom
Piqué and Drollex and Patrick Philipp
are all in family hands, they are
some Swiss families or
French or whoever brats,
they are mostly in the hands of
Swiss families
and then there are three large
listed groups, one of which is
LVMH  Group that owns a few en-brands
richement that owns many en-brands
and the Swatch Group, which also
owns a lot of luxury brands, these are
the principles that are the big ones with
the so there are a lot of
contacts and dialogues
and I think there is now a
certain level of appreciation  also for what
we do, which probably wasn't always the case 10 years ago,
i.e. how
we deal with data, the proximity we
have to our customers, the
information we have about these customers
and everyone finds that
very fascinating and entertaining  You're
also welcome to talk to us about it, but these
tend to be conversations that take place on a
smaller scale and not privately
than on the big
public stage, okay, but you know
each other and one of them or a
Rolex like that ends up saying something similar to
a Bucher  MVE are responsible for almost
half of the volume here anyway, we
would be interested in buying something like that, so
from the
capital power they could
probably have, I think there are
few companies that have the capital power
like Rolex, the company is in
one  Foundation and almost no
money is taken out of it except for
things for charitable purposes and
a little to provide for the family but that is the
company is doing
very very very well so that will
certainly not fail but you
certainly have to open the question quite openly
What is the strategic benefit
for us of such a
partnership? I mean, our
business has developed
so successfully over the last few decades
and even if we
look ahead to the next 10 20 years,
we are extremely optimistic and
believe  that we
are now just at the beginning of one
another, so yes, it is estimated that
in 10 to 15 years the used watch market
will be just as big as the market for
new watches and all of the
services that
can be offered to new, new collectors  come into the market
so that works, you
can do it yourself, you can
model it quite well by
simply looking at how many watches have been
sold in the last 10 20 30 years
and brought into the market and the
watches don't disappear, they
stay  and you can then
model quite well after how many years
watches will be resold on average
and that's why these
models are relatively stable on the used watch market
and the potential
for buyers is still very, very large -
I mean, China did it 20 years ago
In America, too, we have seen
a huge boom in watches over the last 5 years,
insofar as the industry is already perhaps 100
years old, we are still seeing
insane growth figures and and and
boom times, currently
negative growth in some segments, so
we are what they are  The long-term future
is extremely optimistic, so the next
generation says that they say screw the watch,
I have an Apple watch or I have
my cell phone, this piece of jewelry, the watch, it's
not that important to me that it wo
n't happen because I think that's always
the pending danger that you always have
I think what's the point with these luxury watches,
it's not necessary at all, but you
say no, it's on a
different level, so it's definitely
not necessary, um, we
agree on that, um, but the
question was asked before 10
The SmartWatch has been discussed very intensively for years,
so the Apple watch in particular will
displace luxury and there were
many, many voices who suspected this 10 years ago
and we were
approached by many hedge funds back then who wanted data from us
in order to be able to predict this better
and we
spoke to a few hgefonds who
bet a few 100 million euros against the watch industry because
they were of the opinion that the industry is going
down at the moment but the
prevailing theory is that there aren't many publicly
listed ones  Would
you have how do you bet against it ne rement and
SWAT Group that was the two brands
against which they bet against
but one is enough if you
are sure that it will go down and a
big bet
will come in and I remember a
conversation with one  hgef manager who was
short over 100 million against richement and
Swatch oh wow it won't be there you
will have lost a lot of money yes yes yes yes
um but now the
prevailing thesis is that the
smartwatches are more of a pioneer
for the purchase of luxury watches
Much more critical than buying a
SmartWatch for the luxury watch industry is
someone and a young person who does
n't wear a watch at all, so if they have the choice, they would
rather have a SmartWatch or no watch
then they would rather have a SmartWatch because then
they get used to a watch and somehow find it
chic or or  I'm
used to having something on my wrist and at
some point I'd like to
have something special. Maybe I'm having
a wedding or another
special day and
I'd like to treat myself to something and
a watch is of course a completely
long-lasting, imperishable piece of jewelry
In such a time when everything
else is thrown away after a short time,
an extreme
passion is naturally required and that's
of course what's great for us, that
we are a company that is always
the companion in these special moments,
whether it's buying a
watch  is a special occasion for a
wedding, an anniversary, a promotion
but perhaps also the sale of a
watch, be it that you need the money to
perhaps pay for your children's education
or perhaps
a very sad case where you lose the
inheritance of the collection of one
Sold to the deceased there are often very,
very special moments when a watch is
bought or sold because they
are extremely long-lasting goods, what are the
collections that are now
listed there, so people keep their depots
with you on average, so at
head level you have to  I have
n't included the exact numbers at the moment,
but there are also
a lot of people who have several million
watches with you. Yes, there
are well over 1000 users who
have uploaded a collection that
is worth over a million euros, okay but
Of course the range is wide, yes there
are also a lot of collections that
consist of a single watch if you
have just bought a watch and there
are many people who just buy
one watch in their life and
that is also okay and
understandable  Finally, what kind of
rischeck are you wearing today?
I think in technical language it's
not a question for me, but for you, yes, I've been wearing it, I've been
wearing it a lot lately, it
's a wascheron Constantin
overseas dual time, I have a lot of
watches with me  with several time zones because
I also have a lot of international
calls and it has often
happened to me that I somehow
mixed up the direction and
called somewhere in the middle of the night
and that's why I find this such an
interesting feature, which is why
I have quite a few  Watches with this
function in the second zone find it quite
interesting to estimate something
between 15 and 20,000 €. That's
exactly the order of magnitude and we have
just published a very interesting
study. We simply
analyzed in our watch
collection in which order to buy
People watches so what is
typically a watch that you
buy at the beginning of a collection and what is
typically a watch that you buy at the end of
a collection and for example
Rolex is a watch that is continuously
equally likely whether it
is my very first watch or my 8
p.m  and wasacheron Constantin is the
brand that has the greatest probability of
being bought at the end of a collection, it's probably also something
for insiders what for insiders so so
silent luxury is also a
big
topic right now that people like to wear luxury
that they can easily  not so easy to recognize
and that is probably a
brand that is one of the least known
and that is why it is only publicly visible at the end of
your collection.
No, no, it is not and at the very
beginning of the collection there is, for example,
tacoya, which is also a watch
It's not quite as expensive, it's also really stylish.
I think it's basically a
good watch, but it's typically not
a collector's watch that gets
bought a lot at the end of a collection. What are there,
what new
marketplace features do you have in mind? I
mean a marketplace like that  That also offers
a lot of possibilities
and I think it's incredibly
smart to open depots like this so that
people can store their watches with you online, so to speak,
online where you
notice, only virtually, but you still
have an overview, you can see the
current valuation and
I looked at the prices for the watch, um, um, what
else do you do with your
marketplace, what kind of plans are there? So, for
example, one thing that we're
publishing right now is, um, a
separate index,
chronopuls, where you can really see on a daily basis
how well it's performing  The whole
watch industry and in particular
how well individual brands perform and
what's special is that we really
do this from real transaction data. There
are already a few other indications
on the market right now that do this based on
watch offers that don't
necessarily have the real value
represent this is a thing that is
coming out right now from a marketing point of view so that
everyone then talks about your index and
you have, so to speak, marketing
abstract effects or can you
monetize it, we don't monetize it
but it is certainly an extremely
strong content marketing feature but of
course also for those who  ohhin
with us on the platform are an
aid to the purchase decision if you
see Hal which brand is developing like this
and so maybe that will also help me to
determine whether I want to buy or sell a watch
Brand goes down
or something like that, well the good brands go
up even over long, long periods of time
over decades and that's how
you know the strength of a
brand when the
prices develop very, very positively in the long term, um and
so do we  We are
currently thinking about other features,
especially for our
sellers and our private sellers, who
want to make it even easier for us
to sell watches via Chrono 24. We are
currently testing the consignment service so that
watches can be sent to us and we can
then sell them for our customers, making
the whole sales process even more enjoyable
much easier to do okay okay
well so
it seems to be progressing with you let's
see how the urame
develops so it was already
extremely strong or is still
somehow impressive
and and how things are progressing now with the
as the player  Number one, who
is who, GI gives you a second one
that you can call that, I
talked about China, about Japan, there are
others, yes, there is another colorful
auction house,
okay, yes, which is one thing that is
now also doing really well
because we have it  We have
n't really noticed it for 10 years,
so we're talking about eBay, yes,
yes, um, but I think eBay has done a
pretty good job, especially in the last few years.
They've also separated themselves a
bit from the competition against Amazon
So ebay is no longer competing against
Amazon and is now trying
to focus very strongly on luxury categories
such as sneakers,
handbags and watches
and they don't do that badly either
but of course they are in a
completely different price league so the
average watch that you have at  Ebay
is probably a third of the
price or a quarter of the price
from us
but they are definitely moving there
too,
with the focus being on the markets
in the Americas, USA, UK and
Germany where eBay is relatively relevant
in others  Markets, EB is not that strong,
okay then build us a German
world market leader or continue to build it,
all the best for that and we will then
perhaps
hear the next update in I don't know ten years, when then
probably some ST
have invested or I have no idea
You are on the stock exchange or or an exciting
trip from Germany, thank you
very much for coming, thank you very much Philip, I
did SP ciao
[music]
ciao